Earlier we said that while the U.S. excels in high technology care,
our overall health care quality,
efficiency, and safety results are poor.
In large part, this is because most health care costs are due to the incurable,
lifelong chronic diseases that our health care system is not designed to treat.
Patients with multiple chronic diseases account disproportionately for those costs.
Here's the opening paragraph of
a 2004 paper in public health reports that I strongly recommend you read.
Quote: In 2000, approximately 125 million Americans,
45% of the population,
had chronic conditions, and 61 million,
21% of the population,
had multiple chronic conditions.
The number of people with chronic conditions is
projected to increase steadily over the next 30 years.
While current health care financing and
delivery systems were designed primarily to treat acute conditions,
78% of health spending is devoted to people with chronic conditions.
Quality medical care for people with
chronic conditions requires a new orientation toward prevention of
chronic disease and provision of
ongoing care in care management to maintain their health status and functioning.
Specific focus should be applied to people with multiple chronic conditions. End quote.
The paper then goes on to describe the care of those patients saying, quote,
while the average Medicare beneficiary sees between six and seven different physicians,
beneficiaries with five or more chronic conditions
see almost 14 different physicians in a year,
an average 37 physician visits annually.
People with five or more chronic conditions fill almost 50 prescriptions in a year.
This stunning fragmentation of the care of the people who drive
most health care costs is the central rationale for interoperability.
This is so key that I'll now interview one of the authors of
that paper Dr. Jared Anderson of the Bloomberg School of Public Health at Johns Hopkins.